[Music]
hey everyone and welcome to theories and
Thrones and today we're talking all
about this series finale of Game of
Thrones I'm exhausted I'm Lea Aguilera
from Entertainment Tonight and I'm also
exhausted and mike rizzo from gamespot
we're excited to start hearing all of
your thoughts about the iron throne we
have a lot to discuss yes start sending
us your questions comments theories and
overall thoughts about this episode so
you can shout it out in the YouTube
comments or you can also tweet us but
it's always where we get started the
thing that we have to say this is an
after show so go away if you haven't
watched the finale yet you're not
freaking out over at the finale you're
about to be because spoiler alert all
the spoilers series finale spoilers ok
what did you guys think about Danny's
death the fact that there is no more
Iron Throne and that the Starks are all
split up tell us your thoughts because
we will be including them plus we're
going to be sharing an exclusive montage
video with the Game of Thrones cast
revealing how they really feel about
their on-screen fate Mike how you doing
right now tell me your quick overall
thoughts about the episode well we got
some comments already and I wanted to
read one because this basically summed
up how I felt well yeah so Kyle Faraday
wrote the places the characters ended
were more or less fine the machinations
and execution to get them there yikes
yeah I agree so my thoughts to this
episode are similar to last week because
I liked this episode and it feels like
there's a parallel universe somewhere
where we got two proper seasons of good
storytelling what Game of Thrones used
to be here yeah and it would feel so
much more satisfying and it didn't like
I I enjoyed most of the beats in this
episode there were things that were
unexpected things that I think ended
really beautifully in a poetic way like
the way we wanted them to like Brienne
writing Jamie's page in the book I just
because of how we got here it just it
feels a little bit cheap I agree
so Justin Lawrence also competent and
said wow there should be another five
seasons after that
episode truthfully I don't think my
heart could stand another five seasons
especially if it was like season eight
but overall I really loved this episode
I thought that it was the best bow we
could have hoped to wrap up on this
season just as certain scenes I felt
like were being too long like for
example like when John was talking with
Tyrion there were certain times where I
was a god this is going on for a long
time but then when I listened to the
content of it I was this is beautiful
and amazing but the beginning part of
the episode did feel a little bit slow
to me and I was like do they not realize
this is the series finale yeah but let's
really jump all into it let's talk about
the biggest question of every Game of
Thrones episode who died who died and
you know who died in this one r.i.p
Daenerys Targaryen yeah we called it
that was that was heavy that was heavy
Mike when you like first of all let's
take it back a little bit danny is there
she's reigning over the left over
unsullied in Dothraki
and you're seeing her mindset what were
your thoughts somebody needs to kill her
like to see her stand on the ashes but
my big problem with that scene and maybe
he was delivered maybe this is the the
the conflicted feeling that I was meant
to have which is she has no self
reflection in that moment about the fact
that she has become the thing that she
always swore she wasn't going to be
which is queen of the ashes
yeah become that but she's standing up
there like this is a huge victory right
she's standing up at the top of those
stairs like we did it and now we're
gonna go do it
even more and I was just like please
somebody put an end to this and it's Jon
Snow who actually put the end to it when
we're seeing them have this conversation
it was that moment before the stabbed
her that my cue and I've wanted this
whole season Emma Green to rule together
to to balance each other out be that ice
and fire blend that we wanted and then
just as it look like he's like you are
my queen I will be by your side you're
my queen down forever exactly we watched
that light drain out of her eyes as he
stabbed her fees I truly like no offense
Jon I did not think you had it in you
yeah I leaned over to
just watch it yeah I mean overly and I
said he's gonna stab her right now yeah
and I can't believe he did though
because most of my predictions about
this fans wanted it to be Arya disguised
as John to be able to do that but John
would have had to have died for her to
be able to take his face there there was
one people have brought this up to me a
lot because I've been talking a lot
about Arya taking various people's faces
throughout this season bran or John or
Jaime and there was one moment in season
six I think when Jacquin wore Arya's
face yes when she was like about to
leave and she was still yes so it is
possible layers to the faceless man yeah
Jake that ultimately don't matter
because it's over we're getting in so
many amazing comments right now crystal
said what a waste
Astrid said I feel as though they made
Danny go mad so quickly so that she
could get killed off which allows for
everyone else's endings this is very
true which leads us into our next death
of the episode
r.i.p the Iron Throne yeah the Iron
Throne which I actually was so pleased
with this yeah get rid of it it's there
was a funny moment before that where she
was talking about what she envisioned a
thousand melted swords to be like yes
which kind of was a meta reference to
the fact that george RR martin always
envisioned it to be this giant massive
there's various like artworks of the
Iron Throne
online like fan art or whatever that
George has publicly said this is more
like what I envisioned where it's this
huge mountain of it yeah swords so I
thought that was a fun moment but drogon
burned it all regardless really I
thought that was incredible so
heartbreaking though to watch drove on
try and wake up Danny and try and wake
up his mother and say she was okay and I
thought this is a really fitting end for
it all and he's a smart little dragon to
realize that that was the reason why his
mom died well I think drogon understands
symbolism a little better than the
actual show runners do yeah how many of
you out there thought the Dro gun was
actually gonna burn up Jon though raise
your hand if you thought for a brief
second that that's what was gonna happen
I was hoping this would be the moment
where Jon macquaire are the whole series
is he going to be a Targaryen or is he
going to be a stark end and he wound up
being a stark but I was hoping that
would be the
where he would have his you know emerged
from the fire unburnt moment like Danny
did at the end of season one mhm and
that would be like he's a Targaryen but
we're gonna talk about that later
definitely let's highlight some of these
comments right now because there's
amazing very Keirsey said certainly CGI
it was definitely rushed I would
actually disagree I thought the CGI in
this episode looks fantastic but I'm so
calm the backgrounds I think looked a
little bit there were moments where I
was like I could I could sense the
green-screen
yes that's never good but I you know
when I sense it the most was when Miss
Sunday died that's when I sense the
greens in the most that whole set in in
Episode four looked completely young
yeah and yeah people compared it to like
overhead like aerial shots that we've
had in King's Landing it's like this
area does not exist doesn't exist it
just looks super fake yeah yeah I
thought it looked great
Nana said I wanted Danny to just fly off
with her dragons technically she did
kind of because drogon just scooped her
on up and then just flew off with her I
mean there's a lot of speculation among
book readers about the kind of dual
warding abilities of Starks with their
wolves and Targaryen with their dragons
because it's never really explained how
Targaryen can control their dragon when
they're right on top of them yeah right
and and the show kind of just glossed
over it when Danny you know got the
Dothraki back you know at her side and
she just kind of went away for a couple
hours and then came back and was just
fully in control of drug on it yeah that
was it and so I have to wonder if that
scene in the books will be a lot
different and it'll be you know Danny
waking up to her these magical abilities
that the show has sort of tried to sweep
under the rug for the last few seasons
and the finals you know scene could be
interpreted maybe is Danny working into
drogon at the last minute yeah living
life as the dragon that she always
wanted to be let's talk about the fact
that Danny is gone and she did not get
to sit on the Iron Throne on it which
leads us into our next segment which is
OMG
øt where we talk about the biggest
moments of the night because you know
what Danny never got to sit on the Iron
Throne the Iron Throne is destroyed and
now it's all hail brand the broken yeah
my favorite joke that I've seen so far
and it's only been a few minutes granted
but I think this one is pretty good is
that is that brand war get into drogon
to melt the Iron Throne to build himself
a ramp for his wheelchair because that's
why he came south so the long game yeah
that's really the long game
for brand but you know I okay so let's
talk about it after Danny died after
drogon flew off with her we got a bit of
a time jump by the length of tyrians
beard I'm gonna say three months yes
well long enough for them all to get
down there long enough for this new
council to all come together depending
which episode of the show we're watching
that could take anywhere from a month to
a few hours yeah apparently I wonder how
quickly it took kendry to run down there
so we had this new council and they were
trying to figure out who was gonna be
the new king and/or queen of Westeros
everyone kind of laughed at Sam saying
oh honey no we're not doing a democracy
they kind they got partway there they
actually got to a representative fantasy
which is kind of what we have yeah you
know whether that works out for them
we'll see they also Sansa had a moment
where she I think ed Muir was starting
to mansplain man's displaying the
situation and she goes sit down uncle I
mean it was I was shocked at how many
characters that we have not seen in a
very long time yes returned in that
scene and it felt like a nice little one
of those scenes that they just needed to
wrap up certain things like yes ed Muir
was rotting in the dungeons at Riverrun
or the twins or I forget exactly where
he was but he's here yeah yes Robin
Arryn is still around somehow
looking pretty good considering he looks
nice nicely been a sickly weirdo yeah
the new Prince of Darkness
okay here is one of my one regrets about
episode 5 is that I would have loved to
have seen the fact that Cersei still had
the Dorne oh my gosh I'm blanking on her
name right now and I'm killing
are you saying Laureus and thank you I'm
so sorry cuz I want to say Marcin
rodding I wanted to see her realize that
the world was shaking and crashing down
around her yeah well a laureate
presumably is dead at this point
yes sir she left her down there long
enough to watch her daughter's body
recomposes super dark stuff no need to
follow up on that that's why I wanted
Cersei to have a more dangerous death
because yeah she was the queen of doing
that to other people
Joshua said Sansa played and won the
game I love that I guess yeah and
Danielle says I was so happy that Sansa
became queen of the north oh we're
definitely gonna be getting into all the
Starks right now we were talking about
that moment to whenever you're watching
because like Yara immediately goes I you
know I for brand exactly then Sansa goes
na and be like wanted the camera to go
back to guard that not change our vote
no I didn't know that we could be just
break away - cuz Ireland's actually
don't want to be part I know I was like
the six kingdoms now yes why does the
North get to be exempt from this and I
was just like bran is bias okay let's
talk about the fact that brand-new this
was happening the entire time okay
and so he pictured this entire thing
happening he might a lot of innocent
people died so he could be king it's
kind of messed up and I feel like the
show did not really reflect on that very
well how do you think that bran is going
to be as a ruler now that he's on the
Iron Throne I mean it's it's it's my
wife texting me right after the episode
ended and she said like how do we think
George you know the author is gonna
build up to this yeah folks compared to
how it happened in the show and I said
I'm guessing he probably won't write
bran as soulless dead-eyed shell of a
person for three seasons I'm eating up
to it because like the brand that we
have come to know in the show is like a
weirdo who doesn't care about anything
and sits around so you can like do side
eyes at people and like I don't I don't
care about that character anymore and so
it felt like I don't know who he is
anymore and he let all even saying to
John like you were exactly where you
were supposed to be like you let all of
this horrible death happen couldn't you
see I could be here yeah couldn't you
have warned people and let them know
like his cheeky little line of
like why do you think I came all the way
down here I was like kind of a dick move
bran like you want to have like this
great moment but like truly that's not
the time or place
I guess the thinking is that Brent would
be a good king yeah because it's always
like you know the person who doesn't
want it is the person who should rule
the most and we've always applied that
to John Sheldon John doesn't want it and
so John would be a good ruler and he or
DubLi would have the same sentiment
could apply to bran it's just I don't I
don't recognize that character as
Brandon Stark he's a shell of you know
and it's very interesting that they're
hailing him as bran the broken not bran
the three-eyed Raven not Brandon he was
named after bran the Builder but I don't
know it just sounds yeah like okay first
the broken I mean it's it's there's a
lot of symbolism in there that I feel
like I'm gonna need 24 hours to unpack
but you know it's interesting you guys
are already sending in so many amazing
comments Matthews was saying drogon was
amazing in a mirror was saying I hope
that drogon would burn John I hated all
that all the Starks survived I mean no
interesting take I would like to point
out that not all the Starks survived
because my boy Rob King in the north our
IP did not survive okay Rob is very dead
and that was crushing and I'm glad no
other Starks died yeah honestly like we
got that all out of the way like I did
feel that some character should have
died throughout the last couple of
seasons to remind us this was Game of
Thrones but they didn't so many people
made it to the last two episodes well
you know what bran might have been the
one who ended up on the Iron Throne but
who actually deserved the Iron Throne
more right after this
damnit don't Narus me Nikolaj
coster-waldau but you don't like when I
say that cuz you think I'm gonna say
damn it you've spoiled him he's gonna
cuddle if you need after all this
you're going to advise me advise you on
what how to get what I want the Iron
Throne perhaps you should try wanting
something else as we go into seasoning
who do you think it deserves the Iron
Throne I mean I do
dammit Daenerys yeah whatever all the
other people who deserve it more but no
I'm gonna say the mother of dragons
should gather I will dedicate myself to
seeing you on the Iron Throne because I
choose you
Khaleesi I was born to rule the Seven
Kingdoms Nikolaj coster-waldau not Jaime
Lannister coster-waldau deserves the
Iron Throne oh no you can't do wrong
yeah but it could still deserve it hold
on I suppose you could go back and
change time couldn't yeah yeah damn it
you've spoiled it totally but that's not
what happened is it he needs to know the
truth I was given to Brienne of Tarth
till I think she's a very strong noble
person and Westeros deserves that I'm
shoot your back and keep your counsel
and give my life for yours if need be I
think Sansa but you don't like when I
say that cuz you think I'm gonna say so
I keep thinking she's gonna say sound
remember oh really and then he's not
that old but I think I think everybody's
got their pluses and their minuses
nobody deserves it all right I wasn't
sure if you'd remember me
Samwell Tarly really yeah he's just the
one that you want to just yeah just a
good thing the best guys he's gonna
cuddle you a good man
oh thank you you need after all this
[ __ ]
yeah he's just a good person he has a
sense of humor he's warm he's pleased
and pathetic he's he's funny he's not
arrogant arrogant he's got it all from
now on wherever you go I go to I want to
say donate I mean I don't want to say
Danny cuz it feels like she's the one
that's put the most effort into
you're like if you were looking at like
a political campaign mm she's put in the
hard yards but she actually has a claim
to it so I probably saved Jon Snow
however I should really say Gendry this
I know but I'd like to see Tyrion on
there because I think he would probably
do the best job given what he's been
through
I think interested to see what he made
about Ned Stark Johnson don't know he
saw something in John and now we've all
seen it - surprised you didn't see Jon
Snow you know I think that I think that
starts should have had its in the
beginning listen to me all right it's
only because you've done more seasons
yeah who deserved it the one gets it
there's only one reward I want I don't
think anyone deserves it I think
everyone just needs to stop being so
obsessed it's bloody
Iron Throne yeah there's so much more to
this bloody story yeah I know and it
causes so much conflict and I just think
let's just yeah what cool debates it's
just a line that I leave it for you guys
does it matter
sir pouch that's what I'd like to see
Anna everyone's just dead and then sir
pounce just hop sir I don't know that
would be great
that's accounts
you
can we talk about surviving he's still
around like there's a lot of cats in the
books that are not in the show and sir
pounce has like a bigger role
this is stupid to say but there's also
like some Tomcat that there's all these
theories that it was Targaryen
princess's cat that's like still around
in King's Landing like biting people on
her ass and an aria chases this cat
around so I wonder if that cat is still
[Laughter]
let's continue on with our biggest
moments of the episode next up let's
meet the new small council because or
should we call them a larger County like
a large council a large council elected
yes sir they're a neat yes every did
they say how often they said we're not
gonna be having the Kings children be
our new king we're gonna once that
person dies then we're gonna reelect a
new king or queen every time but we did
get a new small council with the Song of
Ice and Fire and I thought that was
really interesting the fact that they
wove that into the show yeah it's it's
this has been a long-standing theory yes
for the book and for the show which is
that at the end of it all Sam will
somehow write the song of ice and fire
which archmaester or may sir Ambrose or
whatever his boss did it I guess but he
helped and he came up with the title so
that theory basically panned out I
thought it was kind of mean that tyrion
is not mentioned in that book apparently
I was fine with it it was also kind of
like Tyrion was the hand to like three
different monarchs depending how you
counted he murdered his father one of
the most powerful lords in Westeros I
feel like you should get a mention
honestly I feel like it also just goes
back to the fact that he had to serve as
brands hand over the king because it was
his punishment so I took me I think
truly Tyrion has only ever wanted
attention and to be known as the
cleverest man alive so the fact that he
wasn't included in the book I found fine
that's true I wonder who's in charge of
Casterly Rock now Oh interesting yeah I
hadn't thought about this we get what we
going when we go like
right after the episode all bearing with
us right now whole thing Jaime's in the
Kingsguard yeah he wants Casterly Rock
E's always trying to get Tywin to make
him Lord of Casterly Rock and accept him
as his son who's Lord of Casterly Rock
now is it just maybe he won't be hand
forever I don't know what did you think
about the fact that bran is now part of
the small Council and that he no who
cares about bran I mean I used to care
about bran I really did and then I feel
like they really kind of assassinated
his character in this last season didn't
have anything to do like I think they
kept him around because people like the
actor and I like the actor and brought
his fun to have around bran didn't
really have a place in this season
interesting and bran as the Lord of
Highgarden is just straight-up nonsense
yeah I mean bronze-y on Royces he's
there he's still hanging out why the
hell would bronze Yan Royce who he's a
badass you know in the books my head can
in his books why would he listen to bran
just because Jamie told Branagh he could
it's just like come on that's what I
think all right it was nice to see this
Sam it's a maester and that he's really
kind of got to live out his lifelong
dream and really be heralded for it so I
thought that that was really wonderful
and it was really sweet though to see
Tyrion really take that small council
meeting so seriously fix all the chairs
and then everyone just messes them right
on up yeah I really liked the the slow
zoom out yes the kind of fade to black
I'm glad that wasn't the ending but it
was an ending yeah and and what that
ending said to me is life goes on yeah
right yeah so much has changed but in so
many ways it's it's business as usual I
was really thinking that they were gonna
end it there but they did it and I'm so
glad they did it because then it led us
into having the we get to shine the
spotlight on the Starks so let's move on
to our next segment which is long live
the Starks
I love the starch I loved the fact that
we had this and it was so great yeah
let's talk about the fact that okay so
we have brand on the Iron Throne
we have Sansa ruling the north we have
Arya going off to find out what's west
of Westeros and then John if you like it
or not
quite sure had to take the black yeah I
did not know that the Nights Watch was
still a sin she was trying to figure out
what a nice watch still exists because
there's no more White Walkers yeah there
although I guess they could
theoretically come back in another 8,000
years or something there's no more White
Walkers there's no more wildlings really
because they're all friends now yes the
wardens brokens
so why did we need a Night's Watch still
well cjm said I think John was just
happy with the wildlings I think so too
I think that's where he wanted to be mhm
and the fact like we can have a whole
section about this later but the fact
that he's with ghost
oh we're gonna freak out over that later
- yeah he but he's back with his people
right like I feel like that was he
always felt most comfortable with that
that's where he felt he belongs exactly
I think it is a good ending for him I'm
sad for you know the Targaryen as a
dynasty as a family because there were
good Targaryen 's as well as bad
Targaryen the fact that he never chose
to embrace his identity as Aegon
Targaryen was really surprising to me
and I do feel like that is something
that we will get a lot more of in the in
the books because I'm glad when the show
did John riding ragel there are so many
details of that that just weren't really
brought up in the show like the fact
that regal is named after John's father
he's a huge deal and there's this whole
other character Quentyn Martell in book
5 who tries to ride a dragon and get
smelted and he's like a prospective
character for that book but like riding
a dragon is a huge deal on the show kind
of played it as this like light-hearted
like neverending story kind of like fun
jaunt for for Danny and John and I
wanted more weight to that especially
given that we're never really gonna get
you know that is this is the end of the
Targaryen this is right Jelani had a
really great comment she said John
didn't deserve the throne because he
didn't want it the most qualification
which I've got to agree about I would
have been truthfully I would have been a
little bummed to see John on the throne
just because he's so adamantly kept
saying I don't want it I don't want it
and then brand who we really thought
didn't want it was like actually
actually actually
I will deny but down here all the way
from the north I'm here for this throne
because I've known that I was going to
get it this entire time yeah if you want
to if you want to read that if you want
to be a glass-half-full yeah we can read
that as brand has seen history and knows
the future I guess and he knows that
he's the best option I guess or at least
that's what he's telling people now
astrid says Samwell 2020 I like that I'm
here for that are they gonna vote every
four years yeah let's see primary
perspective says I would love an aria
spinoff yes I would love Ann arias went
off to do I think Maisie Williams would
be into it probably not yeah she
probably wants to she's probably sick of
this as anyway she wants to deliver
online I'm sure I do like what shady
said a few minutes ago which is aria is
the next Columbus oh she's just like
gonna go filling maps now I guess like
that was that was a line that she had
earlier in the series that a lot of
people pointed to is like this is
probably where her story is gonna you
know and ultimately and it did you know
I think it's okay for some things to be
predictable well I was happy about that
because you know she didn't want to be
kendrys lady she was never the lady of
Winterfell that was sonses whole deal
but oh my god to see them say Queen in
the north for Sansa I screamed at our
screen and I think I hurt your eardrum
so I'm really sorry I was screaming - it
was incredible it was so great to see
her she had such an amazing crown yeah
she looked she looked awesome and her
dress was like the the red flowers on
the white cloth where would was some
great I mean the costumes in this show
have been fantastic
yeah not to bring up King Robb alright P
again but to hear them yelling for the
third time a new monarch in the north we
got King we got Kingman North King in
the North season one you know the finale
like back when we were in it we were in
the trenches in the north yes I was like
that's one of the most hype moments in
the book and then see and Lyanna Mormont
really do that for John I also high as
Danny or as Sansa said that she wanted
that for him but then you realize it was
sinking in with her in that moment maybe
she wanted to be clean well she's the
true stark well
they're always neat there's there's a
sing in the books which always needs to
be a stark in Winterfell and John is a
he embraces his you know darkness but
he's not really a stark he's you know
it's a patriarchal society in the
literal sense in that you know family
names are passed down on the father's
side so he is a Targaryen so it would
not it would not have fit for him to
wind up being the king in the north
ultimately yeah Queen in the north
though John says wiping out all the
Starks would have been a fitting ending
something of a shock value zero shock
this season I would agree
I would agree there wasn't a really
truly shocking death this season I was
shocked at the death of the writing
throughout episode yeah no I agree like
Rhaegar was sure a girl's death was
shocking Reagan's death was shocking in
a really frustrating and really bad way
because just it was it was shock value
but not the right kind yeah the red
wedding that's shock value but it's
something that we can look back at the
events leading up to it and saying yeah
this all made sense yeah reg all dying
is shocking because it doesn't make
sense yeah they got ambushed and like
we're not gonna relitigate all of this
but i agree i think i think there could
have been something a lot more shocking
and one of the things that i love so
much about earlier seasons of Game of
Thrones was when it when there was a
betrayal there were the tiny nuggets
that led to it so that like for example
when Shaye betrayed Tyrion and turned on
him that was such an amazing moment
where you realized it and there in the
courtroom and like never understood why
it happened but you didn't see it coming
Jon killing Danny on the other hand it
was satisfying but it was either Jon was
gonna kill her ara is gonna kill her or
I feel like it would have been shocking
if she had killed Jon yeah or if she had
killed tyrion or something
Ramy asks what is the point of john's
whole identity this is something this is
something i just talking about at the
end right
is the fact that he is the last
Targaryen in the end doesn't matter what
what it really was was fodder for the
conflict between John and Danny mhm and
that's disappointing to me I think I
think I wanted that to matter more I
wanted his identity to matter to him
more yeah that's what it really was it
seemed to affect him he never really and
this is this is everybody took pride in
it it's what's lost in the show is
getting their inner monologue and you
know they're their inner lives of the
character like I feel like I know Jon
Snow so well because I have read dozens
of chapters literally in his head
telling me his every thought right and
some characters in the show like for
example I think Iran is probably the
least fleshed out character that you
know at least in terms of the characters
I made it this far I think this episode
in part was good because he was in it
every time he's on the screen I'm just
cringing but you know compare compare
those two characters and I think it's
another thing that we'll have to wait
for the books yeah fingers crossed come
out someday yeah to really find out how
he feels about that because all we get
from him is you know denial saying I
don't want this I don't you're my queen
I never you know it was just another
thing that kind of happened off screen
oh speaking of finding out feelings we
have compiled a montage of everything
the Game of Thrones cast has told Haiti
about their reactions to film in the
last episode and it's something take a
look are you happy with how things ended
yeah you people are in for
talk to me about your reaction when you
read the script for your final episode a
wife I was I was really pleased with
that I mean I thought they did an
amazing job overall with over the whole
whole season but with Jamie also just
really yeah it made sense I was just
like numb I was just numb when I read
like my last page it cuz it's just so
sad it's so sad that like that is the
last time like I'm reading my character
you know and it's just just had to go on
a long long walk it felt like cuz
knowing how the whole thing ends it felt
like you had suddenly sort of burdened
with this huge huge secret that millions
of people around the world wanted to
wanted to know I think that we were just
relieved I well I was certainly relieved
that we had an ending that we could send
out into the world and be proud of and
happy to talk about it I was really
happy yeah I was really happy please
have you shot your final scenes yet and
are you happy with how things ended bad
season ever
what was it like shooting those final
scenes though and you knew it was mine
say Sabbath anyone gets ready for the
emotion and everyone's that being like
oh it's gonna be the lot how many more
takes are we gonna we're just gonna and
then it kind of wears off it was just
really emotional like I feel like
everything you do it's like you can
start to get yourself so down being like
this is the last time I'm gonna read
script and it's like the last time I'm
gonna be in this location and like it
got to a point where I had to just stop
doing that I was gonna just have like a
nervous breakdown yeah I was very
excited mmm I'm very happy for the way
that my character is gonna end up with
game of France I just remember thinking
oh the boys you've done a good job I
remember when I read the final episode
okay I got up and actually genuinely had
some pace around my flat for bit Wow
there you go that was just cuz my leg
said this is sort of just seems like an
added bonus that we're getting to watch
it and celebrate it now I'm um it's I'm
kind of I said to Rose the other night I
was like we've been tethered by this
show for a long time we've loved it and
now we get to enjoy the fine on the
wrong it took me a long time to actually
digest the storyline this season I
thought they did a good job
listen not everybody's gonna be happy
not everybody's gonna be sad it's it's
it you have to remember we're a bit like
real-life we're not gonna take pink
pretty ribbon on this show it's probably
not gonna happen well that'd be fair to
say yeah I thought all of the things you
could possibly feel and hopefully that's
what people will feel when they see
there are no better writers in
television and Dan Weiss and David
Benioff they ended it brilliantly better
than I could have imagined and you
people are in for
oh my gosh we got to talk about these
comments because you guys are killing me
right now
the ancient Lantern said yeah just
finished the episode I'd like the last
10 years of my life back please God dude
that's too real I'm not think I'm ready
to I know more yeah let's see when the
books come out then I might have well
it's Jenny says I actually cried when
ended Katie says agree worst season ever
I want my time back yeah okay honestly I
cried when this season began like I was
very emotional at the outset of this
season watching the first episode I was
at the premiere
we were both seeing it though in that
giant auditorium with the cast there and
it was a lecture animation it really did
feel like we were in for something great
this yeah and then even seeing Jon ride
a dragon even or like even at the time I
was like that didn't happen that's not
how I would have done yeah but even just
the sight of it was so emotional I was
just like I was crying throughout that
episode and I feel like I've become
slowly more dead inside as the season
has gone on which it sounds like some of
our commenters feel the same way well
get fully into that let's talk about one
of the first things that we wanted to
discuss more fully which was Brienne
finishes Jamie's story which I thought
this was such a great moment let's talk
about this Mike because this was
something that you really wanted to
highlight I I it's if we were going live
tomorrow morning I would have looked up
well in the show this took place but
there was a scene earlier in the show
highlighting that book and I think a lot
of people who maybe haven't been
following it as closely as you and I do
we're going what is this giant book
she's writing yes right yeah but I love
when Game of Thrones remembers its own
history and it has things that it can
pull from the past it was so emotional
seeing her flip through this and
realizes that Jamie's pages vanish I'm
gonna go through and look at every
single her third day out there and I
want to read that page but it was so
great to see this and and Mike you made
such a really great point that you see
the difference of his handwriting and
that was one he had to go from being
right-handed Yeah right right there I
interpreted that as you know their
afternoon is although
now looking at the text now I'm not sure
but regardless this was something from
the the books that it's you know Jamie
has a whole chapter I think in book book
four or five I think it must be book for
but he has a whole chapter where he's
flipping he's kind of casually flipping
through this this book of the King's
Guard that chronicles the the deeds that
every member of the Kingsguard going
back hundreds of years has done and his
pages just you know sparse yes and he's
thinking about his legacy and it's this
really beautiful chapter and how he
wants to do something worthy of the
other names in this book Sir Arthur
Dayne and the previous Kingsguard
members and so for Brienne who you know
she's not presumably you know again I
want to go back and try to zoom in and
see everything that's on that page but
she's not just writing you know he freed
ended the siege of Riverrun without
bloodshed he died protecting his queen
yeah she hopefully is writing his legacy
she hopefully is writing you know he
saved King's Landing from burning the
first time Tam like all of the things
that very few characters know about
Jaime but here's the one thing that I
wanted her to write in that book which
was he's the father Brienne of Tarth
baby yeah die for that means Queen
impregnated sir Brienne of Tarth I would
die and I need to go back and scroll
back up and make sure that I didn't
quite miss that commenters i lo agrees
with you Brienne's baby brianne's baby
with multiple question marks i know
that's one of those things I wanted I
wanted her to stand up when she closed
the book stand up from it and have them
yeah that would've been great I know
that that you don't need to have
children in order to be happy as a woman
but she was so devastated when he left
it would have been nice if she had a
little bit of a piece of him with her
forever yeah I think that's one of those
things that's going to have to leave in
our imagination yeah yeah let's talk
about the one thing that got me through
this season the one thing that honestly
I teared up I was so excited okay yes we
did cry a little bit of this John
finally Pet ghost
he finally pet goes we thought so like
but we're in the office we were in the
we just I shrieked yeah a lot of people
were like are you okay what is happening
right now thank God look at this scene
let's just look at it John not petting
goes throughout John ghost being absent
for the last two and out my god he gets
a little kiss it's been the worst it's
like I'm a dog person even if you're not
like pet your dog rays II know it was it
was great that that to me made up for a
lot it was the only ending that I needed
like anything else could have happened
and I overall my lasting feeling from
this episode is that John petted his dog
he's in like honestly like John will
take no wife he will bear no children
but he has his he has his dog and like
that and his best friend yeah I want to
be John and Herman's adventure John in
torment adventure I I just I loved I
loved that moment and it was like it
that was that was really the moment that
I was like we were watching that montage
and I was sitting my seat just gritting
might just gnashing my teeth going
where's that dog he's got it he'd better
pet that dog man and then he did and
then he did and then we were happy let's
read some of your happy or not so happy
comments right now I'm Gris Bell says
Howard sama Meister to the King no less
archmaester archmaester of the kingdom
so Summa bleah some time has passed or
maybe they just I mean they put him on
the fast track to graduation I guess
yeah Pikachu says I swear they filmed
that scene a week ago cuz of our
complaints meeting John petting ghosts
I would not authorised yeah they just
they composite that in afterward I would
not be surprised at all the backlash
we've all read a lot about how hard it
is to yeah let's watch it again yeah
Jenny says yes I love ghosts
he was like you or a good boy ghost I
love you boy just I feel like it's been
at least an entire season since we just
saw John smile or maybe since the first
that went him and Danny when he and
Danny were making out in the first
episode of assassins did he smile back
he smiled when she was like come kiss
your queen yeah John is such like a
broody
yeah which I love about him but he's
such a broody sad boy that like a John
Snow smile is rare and it's a beautiful
sight and especially when it when it
relates to good boy goes you're such a
fanboy right now and I love it
we're gonna take a couple more of your
comments we have Randy says John saved
the world twice then goes back to ghost
and the real North that's that's not
satisfying I'm fine with John's ending
I'm fine with it I don't know I feel
like there's probably a few a few
different camps amongst people who
wanted John Austin that I'm just I think
I think John ruling would have would
have been great it would have been a
challenge for him though yeah he doesn't
want it it's it would have been like him
accepting once about it yeah we've
talked about this a lot right that he he
gets power and authority and
responsibilities put onto him by other
people all the time and the compromise
of you know he I believe was the 998
Lord Commander of the Nights Watch and
now he's also the 999th commander I
guess cuz he died and now he's swear
does he has to go does he have to go
swear the words again yeah there's some
logistical stuff there but I feel like I
feel like that's a good ending for him
that's kind of like his version of a
peaceful ending as he gets to go you
know he found out that he was dirt or a
Targaryen you know twenty years into his
life or whatever he's always felt like a
stark he gets to go be a stark in the
north with his wolf I have a question
for you yeah what did you did you think
that we were ever going to like meet Jon
Snow as a Targaryen and like did you
think that we were gonna start calling
him Aegon Targaryen at that point you
never thought I kept waiting for a
moment like when he transitions into
Aegon and we stop calling him John scrap
we seen him really take ownership of his
identity and I'm echoing the same
thought that I had early on this episode
but had we really seen him take pride in
that and challenge Danny and and think
of himself as a potential heir to the
Iron Throne then we as an audience would
have stood behind him and maybe started
calling him a conqueror
yeah that's what I was thinking I just I
I kept waiting for a moment when I
stopped thinking of him as snow yeah and
even you know writing I write a lot
about the show and I always write John
snow and right when that reveal happened
I I started writing John snow slash
Aegon Targaryen
we're like John GaN snow Darion or
whatever like I was combining them in
weird ways like [ __ ] but it just it
never happened and I I just noticed you
know that we've just gone back to he's
just John snow in the end he's not John
Stark he's not Aegon Targaryen what are
some of your and like yours and yours
unanswered questions of the season
because I have quite a few but one of
the things that I was initially thinking
of is and it just escaped my brain right
now because we're so excited but what
are some of your biggest unanswered
questions right now there's someone
there's so many things that happened off
screen yeah that I feel like I say this
I'm harping on this essentially but like
things that I look forward to reading
the full version of then they cut for
time yeah Arya and Sansa reacting to
learning about Jon's true identity right
like Jon getting arrested like we were
watching him murdered - Queen yeah and
you know drogon flies away and it's like
what how was he gonna get out of this
room what is gonna happen next and then
we get a tight you know the next scene
is Tyrians beard is this long we go was
there it was that a time job yeah what
the hell so we don't get to see there's
there's I'm sure more things will come
to me you know as as we think and write
about this episode endlessly but but for
me like there were just so many things I
wanted to see how that ultimately got
cut
I remembered good um who are the green
eyes that Arya was supposed to kill oh
yeah I mean is the lesson prophecies
doesn't it doesn't always come true is
it that this prophecy was different than
what was actually in the book so they
didn't feel that they need that was a
show prophecy that she gave her so
honestly had Arya at the last minute
killed one last person before she left
and it was
green eyes she just remember she's
getting in the boat she goes oh hang on
a second
he was green eyes okay yeah here's one
what did varus what was the voice that
he heard in the flames that's that's a
story from the books it's a story from
the show it's something that the show
strangely called back to when yeah oh my
god am I gonna remember her name
Kim Navarro was that her name Wow that
was impressivee I think that was he
might it might tell me if I'm wrong yeah
the red priestess who showed up in
marine in seasons five or six for one
episode she mentioned that cjm says the
reference to the child sacrifice and
babies with the night king right I mean
I think it was just that those were the
night Kings generals and that they were
all Craster's kids and we were just
supposed to assume that but yes I would
have loved in the final scene when Jon
and the wildlings were walking up north
how great would it have been if they had
stumbled on dead bodies in another
swirling some yeah and the cycle
continues I would have loved that it
wouldn't made no sense but I would have
looked at it or if we had learned
something more about the White Walkers
and what they wanted beyond kill
everyone
mm-hmm in the last scene is sorry and
the last scene is is you know John and
the wildlings going north and they enter
the forest they enter clearing and the
you know the White Walkers come out and
they're brokering a peace now with them
mm-hm
you know in a cycle doesn't continue one
of my favorite theories that I am
choosing to believe is is partly true
because I think it would have been
incredible was that the big twist would
have been that the night King was not
evil and that it's actually the
three-eyed Raven that's evil and that
bran died once the three-eyed Raven took
over his body and what actually had
would have happened was that the night
king was looking to kill the three-eyed
raven from getting power because he was
actually the one that was gonna be the
doom of men yeah I mean the anything
that we got could not be furthermore the
opposite of that would have been so cool
what about what about like I saw it I
think this was a reddit comment I saw
recently but the fact that the White
Walkers came to Winterfell and those are
I believe were meant to believe that
there Craster's sons right from over the
decades and and Craster's last son is at
Winterfell in the crypts with Gilly
not just I it would have been really
cool for there to be some moment we got
a kid because it seemed like that kid
was like a Chekhov's gone on the wall
like exactly wound up not mattering well
and Tasha's biggest question is where
did bran go during the Battle of
Winterfell when he worked out of there
and was like hey BRB yeah that's more of
a question for the writers like I I
don't I don't that's not something that
I necessarily want to know because I
don't think there is an answer had it
had it been a big reveal and it's like
they helped to win that battle because
bran was doing this work thing then that
was angry like I still want I still
wanted brand to have worked into undead
vissarion yes or something but it said
John J's yell at him another thing I
wanted to see is is John and Danny
having a conversation about Aemon
Targaryen and I was I was thrilled that
Amon got a shout out in this episode
right as soon as as soon as he said that
quote and he was talking to Tyrion as
soon as he said that quote love is the
death of duty
I went Amon season two and he said it
right afterward so they remember that
Amon exists but like nobody thought they
should tell Danny that like her
great-grandpa or someone tell me someone
will correct me on their exact
relationship but that she had a family
member alive at the wall all this time
mm-hmm super sad super sad I think that
I think we've discussed as bad as much
as we can for this considering we are
going off of no sleep right now it's not
trying to process this episode it sounds
like you guys are all pretty conflicted
as well so keep commenting and keep
tweeting us with your thoughts thank you
so much for tuning in tonight and for
this entire season of theories and
thrown yes it was it was bittersweet
that's what they said and you know I
feel that right now but regardless it
has been really fun and really great to
talk about this here with you and with
all you guys here all your common
thoughts and theories about the final
season as this has wrapped up and it's
the end of an era yeah and if you have
any lingering feelings about how you
think this season should have ended you
can always tweet my can have its
occupant a lot of thoughts thanks again
for joining us for theories and Thrones
this season and I guess we won't be
seeing you until we come together
our next show there's a prequel coming I
mean oh God bye guys bye
[Music]
you